der mysteriöse fall der schulzes
austrage von einem tag auf den anderen
verschwindet die familie 2015 aus einem
kleinen dorf in niedersachsen
spurlos passanten finden später den
vater ertrunken am elbufer doch von
mutter und tochter fehlt bis heute jede
spur
[Musik]
und wir schauen zunächst auf dieses bild
hier was sehen wir eine mutter umarmt
ihre tochter ja es ist silvia schulze
aus trage mit ihrer damals zwölfjährigen
tochter miriam eine foto wasser glück
und auch geborgenheit transportiert und
die beiden die sind seit dem sommer
2015 fern ist spurlos verschwunden ein
ungeklärtes schicksal das uns wirklich
nicht loslässt weil es so unfassbar
mysteriös es wurde monatelang jahrelang
nach den beiden gesucht ohne erfolg nur
der vater und ehemann der wurde kurz
nach dem verschwinden der beiden frauen
tot am ufer der elbe aufgefunden mit
einem beton klotz am bein ja und die
frage die bleibt natürlich hat er seine
familie ausgelöscht und sich danach
selbst das leben genommen oder war doch
alles vielleicht ganz anders unser
reporter thomas knoop der hat mit der
tochter der verschwundene silvia aus
einer früheren beziehung gesprochen
bilder die eine glückliche familie
zeigen die schulzes austragen marco und
silvia und ihr wunschkind die damals
zwölfjährige medien sie wird geliebt
besonders ihr vater hat ein inniges
verhältnis zu ihr berichtet ihre
halbschwester sabine miriam ist ein
aufgewecktes fröhliches mädchen hat
viele freunde ihr großer traum sie
möchte einmal tierpflegerin werden
pferde sind ihre große leidenschaft am
liebsten geht sie reiten doch ihre
reiterferien wird sie nie antreten denn
miriam wird seit dem 23
juli 2015 kam ist genau wie ihre mutter
silvia bis heute beschäftigt ermittler
journalisten und angehörige vor allem
die eine frage
leben mutter und tochter noch irgendwo
oder hat jemand die gesamte familie
ermordet hat gar der vater frau und
tochter getötet
das ist auch das was in meinem kopf
vorgeht das mädchen war 12 und hatte ihr
leben noch vor sich
[Musik]
dann wirklich so verzweifelt zu sein
auch die kleine mitzunehmen und
ja und da wünsche ich mir manchmal halt
einfach hätte er sie einfach irgendwie
mit einem koffer vor meiner tür
abgestellt
bild chefreporter thomas knoop ist von
der ersten stunde an mit dem fall
schulze betraut sechs jahre recherche
und noch immer keine antwort auf die
frage was ist geschehen und warum gibt
es bis heute keinen hinweis auf den
verbleib von mutter und tochter
wie kann es sein dass menschen einfach
spurlos verschwinden
[Musik]
wie kann es sein dass es von einer
mutter und ihrer tochter seit sechs
jahren wieder ein lebenszeichen gibt
noch ihre leichen gefunden werden
konnten
bis heute gibt der fall schulze auch den
ermittlern rätsel auf alle spuren
führten ins nichts alle hinweise sind
abgearbeitet
wenn so ein fall offen bleibt dann hängt
das an den kolleginnen und kollegen
[Musik]
letztendlich ist dass das was für alle
seiten total frustrierend und
nervenaufreibend ist dass wir so wenig
wissen über den konkreten ablauf und das
wir vor allen dingen
das definitiven ende nämlich das
auffinden von mutter und tochter nichts
haben so dass das immer noch
ungeklärt ist
[Musik]
im sommer 2015 ist der fall schulze das
top thema in der hamburger bildredaktion
schnell macht der fall der vermissten
familie austrage 25 kilometer südöstlich
von hamburg bundesweit schlagzeilen
wo ist familie schulze
von dieser brücke sprang ein vater in
den tod
[Musik]
hier suchen sie ihre leichen
für berichte ich seit über 20 jahren
über die kriminalfälle die hier
norddeutschland oder ganz deutschland
passieren das ist jetzt schon ganz
besonderer fall für mich der lässt einen
auch persönlich einfach nicht los
natürlich hat man einfach nur 1 1 ein
ziel am ende das der fall trage wo eine
ganze familie von einem tag auf den
anderen verschwunden ist einfach nur
gelöst wird
der chefreporter thomas knoop trifft
sabine zucker silvia schulzes tochter
aus einer früheren beziehung und miriams
halbschwester mit 16 jahren ist die
heute 30-jährige zu hause ausgezogen und
hat mittlerweile ihre eigene familie sie
offenbart unserem reporter dass sie
ihrer verschwundenen mutter noch
regelmäßig sms nachrichten auf ihr handy
schickt der letzte nachricht dass
tatsächlich erst ein paar wochen her und
das mache ich einfach ist es so eine art
tagebuch es ist eine einseitige
kommunikation
demir aber hilft in wie
dinge die in mir sind doch noch
loswerden zu können in ihre richtung
[Musik]
es ist mittwoch der 22 juli 2015 ein tag
vor den sommerferien
wie schon die tage zuvor klagt miriam
auch an diesem morgen über
bauchschmerzen
ihre eltern beschließen deshalb dass
miriam zu hause bleibt weil ihr vater an
diesem tag frei hat kümmert er sich um
seine kranke tochter silvia schulze
macht sich auf den weg zur arbeit bei
einem discounter nur wenige kilometer
von ihrem haus in drage entfernt seitdem
gesagt er arbeitet dort wohl einen anruf
bekommen von ihrem mann dann nach einem
tag möglicherweise mit dem inhalt dass
ist der tochter die an dem tag nicht in
der schule war so krank gemeldet war
nicht gut gehe deswegen sie vorzeitig
die arbeitsstelle verlassen hat und dann
nach hause gefahren ist um 16 uhr 20
verlässt seeberg ihrer arbeit im elf
kilometer entfernten geesthacht um 16.50
verbindet sich ihr handy mit dem
heimischen wlan netz in frage danach
gibt es von silvia schulze kein
lebenszeichen keine nachweisbare spuren
er gegen 17.25 telefoniert marco schulze
noch zu hause mit dem besitzer eines
reiterhofs dem er gelegentlich aushilft
er soll auch am nächsten tag donnerstag
arbeiten
doch marco schulze zögert berichtet der
mann später der polizei
was in die nächsten zwei stunden
geschieht konnte bis heute nicht
rekonstruiert werden um kurz nach 19 uhr
ruft miriam super an doch niemand geht
ans telefon
[Musik]
eine halbe stunde später um 19 30 ruft
markus schulze seinen schwiegervater
zurück erzählt dass es miriam und seiner
frau nicht gut geht sich beide schlafen
gelegt hätten doch was ist in den zwei
stunden zwischen diesen beiden festnetz
anrufen zwischen 17 25 und 19 uhr 30 mit
miriam und ihrer mutter geschehen
zeugen beobachten an diesem abend noch
wie marco schulze mülltonnen vor die tür
seines hauses stellt
was sich tatsächlich am späten
nachmittag beziehungsweise durch die
ganze nacht hindurch ereignet hat müssen
wir bis heute nicht es gibt eine weitere
zeugen die den familienvater noch am
donnerstagmorgen
eine am auto in frage wiederum gesehen
haben will wie er dort vorbei fuhr
danach verliert sich die spur als silvia
schulze am donnerstag und auch am
freitag nicht zur arbeit erscheint gehen
bei der polizei die ersten
vermisstenmeldungen 1 die beamten
durchsuchen das haus finden geldbörsen
handys und ausweise der familie auch
beide autos stehen vor dem haus
es deute nichts auf beispielsweise eine
auseinandersetzung hin ein kampf der da
stattgefunden haben könnte es deutet
nichts darauf hin dass die familie
möglicherweise verreist war und nun in
die man bescheid gesagt hat und das war
eben in der summe so dass die kollegen
gesagt haben hier ist mehr passiert als
einfach nur ein spontaner wochenendtrip
wir müssen hier weitere maßnahmen
treffen
es beginnt eine groß angelegte
suchaktion im ort und der näheren
umgebung wo ist familie schulze noch
geht die polizei von einem unglücksfall
aus auch bild chefreporter thomas knoop
ist von diesem zeitpunkt an mit dem fall
betraut als mann mit den nachbarn
gesprochen hat und die alle sagten die
familie gilt als super zuverlässig und
auf einmal ist sie weg da hatte man so
das erste mal das gespür da muss
irgendwas passiert sein im fokus der
weiteren suchmaßnahmen der trucker
strand eine beliebte badestelle an der
elbe unweit des wohnhauses der familie
im laufe der nächsten woche suchen
polizei und feuerwehr auch hier immer
wieder nach der familie später nach den
leichen von silvia und miriam schulze
wir waren so nah boote im einsatz
taucher haben hier den bereich abgesucht
um die ganzen bogen köpfe herum immer in
der annahme möglicherweise weil dieser
ort doch ebenso eine rolle spielte im
leben dieser familie dass hier moderne
tochter zu finden wird seit mittlerweile
einer woche gilt familie schulze als
verlust freitag der 31 juli 2015
lauenburg an der elbe rund 25 kilometer
von trage entfernt am frühen morgen
macht eine anwohnerin eine grausame
entdeckung im seichten wasser der elbe
nahe der lauenburger altstadt treibt ein
lebloser menschlicher körper
kurze zeit nachdem diese nachricht bei
der polizei eingeht macht sich auch bild
chefreporter thomas knoop auf den weg
zum fundort der leiche
die ermittler zum und zogen sich über
stunden hin und erst kurz vor
mitternacht war denn der tote der aus
der elbe gezogen wurde war der von ihr
vater
[Musik]
am 22 juli 2015 verschwindet familie
schulze austrage bis heute spurlos neun
tage später wird der leichnam des
familienvaters aus der elbe geborgen
bis heute geht die polizei davon aus
dass markus schulze von dieser brücke
gesprungen ist und sich selbst das leben
genommen hat todeszeitpunkt laut
obduktion die nacht vom 23
auf den 24 juli
die umstände des auffindens waren ja
auch durchaus sehr ungewöhnlich
beispielsweise war der leichnam mit
einem spanngurt
entwickelt an dem einen ein beton fuß
hin und
letztendlich konnten wir dann im zuge
der weiteren ermittlungen feststellen
dass diese erkrankung von einer
baustelle genommen worden war
da mutter und tochter immer noch
vermisst werden gehen die ermittler
zunächst davon aus dass markus schulze
auch seine frau silvia und tochter
miriam getötet und in der elbe versinkt
hat
wir haben dann natürlich umfangreiche
suchmaßnahmen in der elbe an der brücke
unter wasser am wasser durchgeführt
dabei konnte ein fahrrad am grund der
elbe aufgefunden werden auf dem fahrrad
selber waren noch spannend wurde
gleicher bauart wie sie auch am körper
befestigt waren zu finden und das
fahrrad konnte letztendlich auch der
familie zu gewonnen werden noch am
selben tag erfährt sabine zenker am
telefon vom tod ihres stiefvaters
auch sechs jahre danach fällt es ihr
schwer über die tage und die
todesnachricht im sommer 2015 zu
sprechen der obduktionsbericht hat wohl
ergeben dass er bis zu sieben minuten
mit dem tod gekämpft haben muss sich
wirklich auf so eine art und weise das
leben zu nehmen zeigt für mich
eigentlich irgendwie davon dass er sich
dann auch für irgendwas bestrafen wollte
nachher
hat marco schulze seine frau und seine
tochter getötet bevor er sich selbst das
leben genommen hat oder gibt es doch
eine ganz andere erklärung
laut miriams halbschwester soll es
zwischen den eheleuten zuletzt
spannungen gegeben haben wollte sich
silvia schulze möglicherweise von ihrem
mann trennen ich glaube man muss
bedenken
dass sie sich trennen wollte und das ja
eher das nicht akzeptieren wollte oder
konnte und dann halt natürlich auch
irgendwie angst hat sein kind zu
verlieren vielleicht war er nicht
besonders belastbar und hat das alles
genommen und sich alles so zu herzen
genommen dass er dadurch so belastet war
dass er keinen anderen ausweg mehr sah
im august 2015 wenige wochen nach dem
verschwinden der familie die
vermeintliche wende im fall schulze bei
der polizei meldete sich eine zeugin
sie gibt an die familie noch am
nachmittag des 22
juli 2015 also am tag des verschwindens
am mühlenteich in holm seppensen circa
50 kilometer von trage entfernt gesehen
zu haben eine erste heiße spur
im zuge der überprüfung dort auch
tatsächlich
geruchsspuren durch mehrere
fährtensuchhunde
anzeigen lassen können die übereinstimmt
die fährte von vater mutter und tochter
angezeigt haben die spuren von mutter
und tochter endeten am see und nur die
spur des vaters wurde um den see herum
bis zur straße zurück angezeigt für uns
ein deutliches indiz dass dieser ort
leben eine rolle gespielt haben mussten
die zeugin will einen streit mitbekommen
haben später schreie und einen knall
bild chefreporter thomas knoop erinnert
sich an die tage der suche am zeh tänzer
mühlenteich
ich stehe jetzt hier an der stelle wo
dann auf einmal die fährte von mutter
und kind endete der sie ist fünf meter
tief und man hat mehrere punkte markiert
waren in 17 insgesamt sind mit sonar
boot ausfindig gemacht worden bei jedem
punkt dachte man jetzt passiert was
jetzt kommt eine entdeckung es passiert
am ende nicht die hunde vierten lassen
vermuten dass markus schulze seine frau
und sein kind hier am see getötet hat
was dagegen spricht am nachmittag hatte
er zu hause noch zwei telefonate vom
festnetz geführt eines mit dem
reitstallbesitzer
eines mit seinem schwiegervater zwischen
diesen beiden anrufen liegen gerade
einmal zwei stunden in denen er die tat
hätte beginnen können doch alleine für
die strecke vom wohnhaus der schulzes in
frage bis zum mühlenteich in holm
seppensen und zurück benötigt man mit
dem auto gut anderthalb stunden so hätte
marco schulze gerade einmal eine halbe
stunde zeit gehabt um einen doppelmord
zu begehen und die leichen von seiner
frau und seinem kind verschwinden zu
lassen
der vater ist ja kein profi killer oder
ähnliches sondern einen familienvater
wie man mir auch erzählte hat er seine
tochter über alles geliebt warum er dann
das vermeintlich perfekte verbrechen
begangen haben könnte erschließt sich
mir überhaupt gar nicht letztendlich ist
dass das was für alle seiten total
frustrierend und nervenaufreibend ist
dass wir so wenig wissen über den
konkreten ablauf und das wir vor allen
dingen
das definitiven ende nämlich das
auffinden von mutter und tochter nicht
haben so dass das immer noch
ungeklärt ist ich hoffe tatsächlich dass
sie gefunden werden auf welche art auch
immer es wird mir klarheit bringen und
klarheit ist heilung irgendwann und
heilung bedeutet für mich dass ich
abschließen kann mittlerweile ist die
soko schulze aufgelöst alle ermittlungen
die das schicksal von miriam und silvia
schulze noch
können liefen ins leere der
vermisstenfall schulze wird zum cold
case
deshalb richtet sich die polizei noch
einmal mit einem appell an die
öffentlichkeit
es wurde sucht die polizei weitere
zeugen die möglicherweise die familie
oder auch nur den familienvater in der
nacht vom 22 auf den 23 juli 2015 oder
sogar in der nacht vom 23 auf den 24
juli 2015 gesehen haben wir wissen nicht
genau zu welchem zeitpunkt der
familienvater sich mit dem fahrrad von
trage nach lauenburg an der elbe bewegt
hat und dort selbst mal zu bedienen
zudem will die polizei wissen wem ist am
juli 2015 rund um den mühlenteich in
holm seppensen etwas besonderes
aufgefallen wer hat beobachtungen
gemacht die möglicherweise zur
aufklärung des falles beitragen und
helfen das schicksal von miriam und
silvia schulze sechs jahre nach ihrem
verschwinden
endlich zu klären
[Musik]